alors cette pensée wow qu'on a sans se
diffuser dans la société les politiques
s'en en parlent les jeunes également
exemples avec ses adolescents qui se
questionnent sur leur identité sexuelle
qui se revendique transgenre ils sont
nés hommes ou femmes mais refuse d'être
assigné alors sexe de naissance et il
demande donc à pouvoir changer de prénom
du masculin au féminin et inversement le
Conseil d'État vient de leur donner
raison désormais les élèves de collège
ou de lycées pourront se faire appeler
par un autre prénom que celui choisi par
leurs parents alors déjà un petit
bonjour à Dimitri je trouvais excellent
le repas oui
il est incroyable
Cyril tu t'appellerais comment voilà
alors est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
ça ça fait énormément parler et c'est
vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
disent oui à l'école on commence déjà à
parler de ça aux enfants est-ce que vous
êtes bon ou contre vous non mais bon ben
non non tu as appelé ton enfant tu
laisses Bernard tu le laisses ça alors
si taper ton enfant Bernard c'est qu'il
est né déjà très bien
à 6 ans de ton fils il vient de voir il
dit j'ai envie de m'appeler Jacky bah
non tu t'appelles Bernard il y a 18 ans
tu décideras à quel âge tu as quel âge
alors je sais pas c'est la pression
va rentrer du j'en ai marre de m'appeler
Éric je veux m'appeler Roger mais non
sauf que Raymond ça existe la dysphorie
de genre c'est à dire qu'il y a des avec
un cordon et qui se sente fille tu peux
dire que ça voilà non c'est vrai il y en
a qui naissier qui se sentent garçon
qui s'appelle petite fille absolument
sublime et c'est ce petit garçon qui met
vraiment en crève parce qu'il veut pas
être un petit garçon il veut être une
petite fille d'accord commence dès l'âge
de 3 ans et il souffre et il est plutôt
6 ans c'est pas un peu tôt là c'est pas
du tout
ils arrivent à l'école tu t'appelles
Thibault et le lendemain tu t'appelles
Martine je suis désolé
si ce mutile des tentatives
pas d'accord parce que moi je que c'est
beaucoup trop tôt là les enfants ils
commencent à se poser des questions donc
c'est pas quand un enfant il commence à
se poser des questions qu'on va lui dire
bah ouais bah tu es trop toi c'est trop
tôt il veut pas lui-même ça se trouve il
va le regretter après on peut pas
changer trois fois
le problème Mathieu mais surtout au-delà
du trop tôt il y a des cas effectivement
dont tu parles qui sont très touchants
mais ce sont quand même des cas
relativement à part et mes 50 000 tous
les enfants se posent des questions à
propos de quelques cas tout d'un coup et
ben autorisé pour tout le monde tout
d'un coup des choix mais non on peut pas
c'est bon là on en fait j'ai pas dit que
c'était très terminé Mathieu pour aider
ces gens-là évidemment mais mais ça n'a
aucun sens Mathieu on ne leur qui vous a
donné la parole
non mais parce que je veux rebondir sur
ce qu'il dit on ne change pas leur état
c'est parce que pire on ne change pas la
réponse
à un instant T de leur vie de les
accompagner et éventuellement si
effectivement cette dysphorie de genre
qui reste un garçon
le temps de s'opposer des questions de
trouver tu
tu t'appelles Norma Martine ou Béatrice
non mais ça veut dire que les autres
petits garçons et petite fille qui eux
moi je trouve que c'est beaucoup trop
tôt pour mettre ça dans la tête des
enfants qui n'ont pas ce problème là
mais pensez aux parents
qui avaient une fille qui avait un
problème je pense aux enfants qui n'ont
pas ce problème là et qui vont se poser
des questions peut-être alors qu'ils ont
exactement
une mode on dit pas oh tiens je vais
être un garçon on est en train de faire
Géraldine
elle a complètement raison il y a plein
de gens qui il y a plein d'enfants qui
se posent pas tu poses pas du tout la
question qui veut dire ah ouais
peut-être tu as raison même parce que ça
peut être marrant moi aussi je
m'appelais pas mais là
non mais c'est vrai je suis à la fin de
l'année je change
c'est pas un déguisement c'est pas un
masque c'est pas mon bébé c'est pas un
déguisement c'est pas un masque soit bon
parce que demain tu as ma place
je suis pas meilleur à votre place que
non non je te confirme là
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas c'est trop tôt c'est pas bien
sûr mais
c'est pas un peu plus fort un jour on
n'est pas un jour
c'est pas c'est pas comme ça ça se passe
qu'est-ce qu'on fait concrètement non
mais concrètement concrètement qu'est-ce
qu'on fait quand un enfant 8 ans qui
disant 12 ans 15 ans viens voir
ça rien à voir sans rien avoir mais ça
n'a rien à voir
ce que disent les gens sur les réseaux
ils ont dit après je te plaît ils disent
après ils peuvent te le reprocher c'est
beaucoup trop tôt tout le monde et les
gens les gens viennent fous je vous Lisa
mais quel le prénom
ça va gérer toute ta vie après on va
arriver tu vas dire mais les mecs je
m'appelle plus Jean-Louis et après tu
m'appelles pas mais là
sexualité les gens c'est Daniel Daniel
moi j'ai très très peur parce que il y a
même plus grave encore que le changement
de prénom c'est que le bloqueur de
puberté on peut le faire entre 10 et 14
ans la plupart des adolescents se
chargent se cherchent en côté sexualité
bien sûr on est en train de voilà de de
mettre des mots sur des mots mais il
faut parler il faut autre chose et puis
imaginer c'est pour le bien-être de ses
enfants qui est je comprends qu'il y en
a qui sentent vraiment très très mal à
leur peau mais on a le temps
bien sûr
on entend il y a 50000 cas dans toute la
France parmi tous les enfants comme elle
a dit qu'elle il faut penser aux autres
il faut surtout arrêter de mettre
l'enfant au milieu à trois ans vas-y
décide mon chéri à 6 ans décide mon
chéri c'est n'importe quoi il a raison
et remettons l'éducation au milieu et
arrêtons de faire les enfants rois
qu'est-ce que ceci bah dis mon chéri
vas-y et après on se retrouve avec des
enfants à problèmes à 14-15 ans j'ai pas
j'ai pas vu j'ai pas vu j'ai pas je sais
pas comment ça arrive s'il vous plaît
s'il y a une petite fille de ciseaux euh
tiens vous parce que vous êtes là
défonceuse de cette affaire non mais
c'est vrai non mais oui
on va voir il y a beaucoup de gens mais
beaucoup de gens ici vous allez voir sur
le fait d'État déjà oui bah conseils
d'État oui Conseil d'État merci euh non
mais s'il y a une jeune fille s'il y a
une jeune fille qui souhaite mettre le
voile à 6 ans
quel rapport
choisi c'est trop tôt est-ce que vous
dites la laïcité moi je veux pas le
voile à 6 ans c'est pas la même chose
que c'est pas pareil que si on doit
choisir
si on peut décider à 6 ans non parce que
l'école est laïque en fait si elle
décide donc
c'est exactement pareil
du tout pareil oui 10%, 80 %, je crois
que la messe élite merci on peut voir le
tweet de Booba s'il vous plaît
merci s'ils peuvent non ça c'est normal
ça c'est pas le Conseil d'État voilà
c'est mon fils rentre de l'école un jour
il me dit qu'il s'appelle Mireille on va
avoir un sérieux problème alors c'était
une banane non mais non mais voilà moi
d'accord avec lui
alors il a dit avec humour mais on est
d'accord ça aurait été la même chose
j'ai appelé mon fils Tristan si un jour
il serait rentré de l'école je leur ai
toujours été à l'écoute mais à 6 ans il
me dit papa je veux m'appeler c'est trop
tôt je leur ai dit que tu veux taper
comme à 15 ans pourquoi pas il y a un
problème à 15 ans pourquoi pas
surtout que ce genre de un enfant qui
décide pas très pas les enfants qui ce
genre de choses je vous conseille d'État
etc ça doit rester dans la famille bien
sûr ça doit être une discussion ça doit
être me réfléchissons parlons discret
qui peuvent pas le dire parce qu'ils
sont maltraités parce qu'il y a de
l'homophobie parce que il y a de
l'Algérie
c'est pas pareil
pour les maîtresse et les professeurs
déjà à l'école vous vous rendez pas
compte il y a des enfants malades il y a
des autistes il y a des enfants faut
s'occuper de tout le monde donc s'il
faut rajouter un problème et se demander
si Stéphanie elle va s'appeler Martin
mais vous pouvez sur la table donc les
maîtresses elles peuvent pas tout faire
je suis désolé face à la maison quand on
vous donne pas la parole s'il vous plaît
notez sur votre carnet non mais c'est
vrai merci euh présenter les 10% qui
sont pas bah c'est très bien mais
c'est bon on a entendu merci non mais
c'est vrai c'est bon merci c'est bon
quoi qu'est-ce qu'il y a Mathieu mais
qu'est-ce qui t'arrive c'est bon on a
entendu
quand même non merci j'ai même pas
demandé la parole
[Applaudissements]
tu es sûr que tu veux te mettre mal avec
moi si tu veux tu es sûr non c'est une
très mauvaise idée non non pas du tout
moi je pense que c'est une très bonne
idée je pense que c'est chez certaines
personnes qui disent qu'ils ont fait 6
heures à 6 ans cette mesure qui ont très
très peur je pense qu'il y a une forme
au sens propre de transphobie
c'est-à-dire n'importe quoi écoutez
comme si c'était une maladie contagieuse
et comme si demain on donnait le droit à
un garçon de prendre un prénom de fille
il le ferait immédiatement parce que
c'est une sorte de tenté n'importe quoi
concerne très peu d'enfants il y a très
peu d'enfants qui se sentent dans le
mauvais corps mais pas du tout une
inséminité tu la respecter toi mais toi
toi toi toi
non mais toi je te le dis bravo
Guillaume en fait toute façon toi dès
que quelqu'un tu es une connerie tu sais
quoi toi aussi tu es comme Gilles tu
représentes la France qui perd
merci